[Música]
hace muchos años cuando estaba en sexto
grado de la escuela recuerdo que me
reuní en una especie de plaza con mis
amigos de aquel momento y resulta que
estábamos como en una especie de
conversatorio un montón de niños
hablando de fútbol de las pasiones de
aquel momento de jugar de disfrutar un
poco en aquel momento sin mayor tensión
y recordamos que unas horas antes
varios de los que estaban ahí habían
visto un anuncio que había salido en
televisión en la que se anunciaba que
brasil quería optar por ser la sede de
la copa del mundo que unos años más
tarde se realizó que fue
brasil-2014 no no se me olvida que entre
todos los que estábamos allí en aquel
conversatorio varios amigos míos que
mencionaron que querían estar en aquel
mundial que qué bueno ir a brasil e ir a
vivir el mundial estar en la gradería
gritar los goles ser aficionado yo
recuerdo que en esa conversación yo le
comenté a uno de mis mejores amigos
y yo me veía en ese mundial que a mí me
encantaría estar en ese mundial y lo vi
como un sueño ese fue como mi primer
sueño pero que yo no me veía en esa
faceta yo no sabía en qué faceta me veía
pero definitivamente lo visualizaba como
algo diferente yo no me veía como
gritando un gol en la grada no lo veía
como algo de esa manera como todos los
demás lo veían yo percibía que me
gustaba estar ahí pero de otra forma en
aquel momento cuando era un niño y demás
todavía no sabía que
evidentemente esa iba a ser mi primera
inspiración para convertirme en
periodista deportivo
unos años después ya grande ya pues
evidentemente había hecho carrera como
profesional como periodista me encontré
a mi maestra de primer grado de la
escuela me contó que ella
habitualmente recogía el periódico la
nación en su casa llegaba en las mañanas
y buscaba en el cierre del periódico si
yo firmaba alguna de las notas porque
ella sabía que yo en aquel momento ya
unos años más tarde no había convertido
en periodista y escribía notas entonces
ella
se sentía como muy ilusionada de saber
que yo escribía artículos en el
periódico luego de que ella pues
evidentemente me había enseñado a leer y
escribir
resulta que en medio de la conversación
empezamos a hablar sobre aquellos
momentos y demás y ella me contó algo
que yo realmente
no recuerdo si realmente no recuerdo
pero me marcó mucho lo que ella me dijo
me dijo josé pablo yo recuerdo que yo le
pedí a todos los
a todos los de aquella clase los
compañeros suyos en aquella clase en
primer grado de la escuela que se
prepararán porque los iba a parar frente
al a la clase a que de alguna manera
hicieran lo que querían ser cuando era
grande y me cuenta mi maestra que cuando
yo me coloque al frente de la clase lo
que hice fue narrar un partido de fútbol
que me puse de escribir una jugada de
agarrarlo y a cantar un gol recuerdo que
en la escuela coleccionaba datos era
fanático los metida debajo de
la debajo de mi cama junto a pósters de
futbolistas y recortes que hacía de
estadísticas también recuerdo que
evidentemente coleccionaba
álbumes de fotografías de los mundiales
y por supuesto estaba siempre el sueño
aquel de de ir a la copa del mundo de
brasil después de que hubiese primer
anuncio pero entonces quizás usted se
pueda hacer una pregunta con lo que voy
a decir resulta que cuando llegue a
quinto año de la escuela a quinto año
del colegio opté por estudiar
veterinaria durante un cuatrimestre
entrará a estudiar veterinaria me fui
con un buen amigo que él sí tenía como
esa vocación siempre recuerdo que él
estaba totalmente entusiasmado con las
giras con el saber
de cuando cuando se aproximaba la visita
una finca para ir a revisar unas marcas
o el ganado o los cerdos o ir a una
veterinaria hacer una práctica para para
ver a los perros y demás recuerdo un día
que nos preparamos para una gira de un
curso y
mientras mi amigo alistaba las botas de
hule para ir a meterse a la finca yo lo
que estaba haciendo era ver un partido
frente al televisor de haití contra
nicaragua de copa oro yo ese día en
medio de ver los ojos de mi amigo con
esa ilusión de irse a la gira y yo con
esa frustración por dentro decir yo
realmente lo que quiero ver es quedarme
viendo acá este partido de haití
nicaragua no me perdí un partido en esa
copa oro lo primero pensé que pensé si
lo primero que pensé fue
qué estoy haciendo aquí
qué estoy haciendo aquí me quedo que hay
que aprender a leer las señales en la
vida
cómo es que mi maestra de escuela sabía
que yo había narrado un partido de
fútbol cómo es que coleccionaba
estadísticas y las metía debajo de la
cama como es que hablaba de ir al
mundial de brasil y que esa era mi sueño
y como llegué a quinto año del colegio y
opté por estudiar veterinaria
evidentemente fue un error tome mi
maleta llené las cosas me monté en el
carro llegué a mi casa le dije a mis
papás les pedí disculpas les dije que no
podía aguantar de un día más que esa no
era mi vocación y al día siguiente
estaba
matriculando periodismo que fue la
carrera que elegí
recuerdo el día que mi jefe me avisó
llevaba muchos años de trabajar en aquel
momento para el periódico al día y mi
jefe me dijo que no iba al mundial de
brasil había trabajado extremadamente
duro y me había matado que me había
quemado las pestañas y mi jefe me dice
es que solo el presupuesto para uno así
que decidí mandar a otro compañero que
tiene más experiencia que usted que ya
sabe lo que es cubrir grandes eventos y
pues no no podrá ir al mundial de de
brasil fue un golpe grande para mí
faltando como unos no sé tal vez
un mes dos meses para el mundial mi jefe
me llama por aparte y me dice ver
tenemos presupuesto pero no total para
su viaje pero tenemos este presupuesto
si usted consigue algo más que le
podemos ir este preso dar este
presupuesto y que usted vaya y cubra el
mundial junto a su otro compañero
casualmente yo en aquel instante era
además de periodista de prensa escrita
en el día era corresponsal de 10 piden
radio para costa rica llamé a eeuu donde
estaba la sele les conté mi situación y
ellos
optaron por poner la otra parte del
dinero y me pude montar al avión y bien
pudiera a cubrir el mundial
ustedes se imaginarán para alguien que
sueño de ir a ese mundial tener la
posibilidad de subirse al avión y estar
ahí lo que significa y fue increíble nos
vimos no voy a decir lo contrario fue
una experiencia espectacular fueron 40
días y conocimos ciudades espectaculares
la gente extraordinaria la experiencia
con mis compañeros increíble cubrir el
mundial más espectacular para costa rica
en su historia recuerdo los vuelos con
la cl viajábamos con la selección en el
mismo avión y el ambiente era
impresionante después de ganarle italia
después de
ganarle a uruguay era como el ambiente
perfecto en todo sentido tener la
posibilidad de hacer de hacer
entrevistas a personajes que quizás uno
veía por televisión que los veíamos
lejanos pero que ahí los tenía a la par
suya como para sacarle ese provecho
y todos son muy muy espectacular y demás
pero recuerdo que un día
me contaron que había un jugador
brasileño en una pequeña ciudad de sao
paulo que se llama santos es una ciudad
playera
ese jugador estaba allí entonces me
tenía que mover como unos 30 minutos
para ir a buscarlo quería ir a contar la
historia del jugador que había militado
en un equipo de costa rica y que ahora
veía la sele y jugar en brasil cuando ya
me trasladaba rumbo al lugar en el que
habíamos quedado de vernos pese a a
ponerle atención a la playa había una
playa
grande así imponente muy bonita un color
como gris una playa no había surfistas y
una playa bastante virgen en todo
sentido y empecé a caer en razón del
montón de playas que me había tocado ver
a lo largo de brasil había estado en
arrecife está lleno de playas
espectaculares
había estado en santos que había mucha
playa en fortaleza que había mucha playa
todas sedes en donde jugué la selección
y ahí en santos cuando en ese momento de
transportar me recuerdo que me quedé
pensando mira estos padres están
espectaculares pero yo mismo me quedé
como como analizando la situación y dije
pero en costa rica también tenemos
playas espectaculares
y me quedé pensando y manuel antonio y
me quedé pensando en playa santa teresa
y me puse a pensar en pues que costa
rica también tenía playas tan increíbles
como las que había en brasil dentro de
la cobertura que hacíamos para el
periódico nos da un espacio para
escribir una columna de noticias más
light más de temas de la vida cotidiana
del brasileño y demás y resulta que opté
por escribir una columna sobre ese tema
sobre las playas de brasil sobre las
playas de costa rica sobre lo que me
había gustado de allá sobre todas las
playas que había visitado en costa rica
regresé a costa rica- seguí en la vida
común y corriente y ya los al tiempo
digo que a los meses diría que casi un
año después
estaba realizando los recortes de los
periódicos de lo que había escrito en el
mundial de las crónicas y demás verán un
poco de nostalgia tal vez recordar lo
que fue aquella experiencia y me
encontré con la columna de las playas la
que había escrito allá en brasil sobre
costa rica y las playas dicen de alguna
manera se me prendió el bombillo y yo
dije qué pasaría
si me voy abre a recorrer cada una de
las playas de costa rica hasta mapear el
país completo y crear una base de datos
de más de todas las playas que hubieran
de diego yo más de 200 porque fue en lo
que en principio hicimos pero de todas
las playas que hubiera en costa rica que
tenía que pasar para lograr eso
y el primero que hice fue llamar a mi
mejor amigo del colegio carlos los doce
éramos de hacer raids de playas comunes
y le pregunté que si él quería entrar en
esta iniciativa adiós a recorrer playa
por playa de inmediato me dijo que si no
no que tú y yo nos montamos en el carro
durante un año completo uno por uno
entonces nos íbamos a recorrer playas
había días en que perdíamos los días
porque decíamos así nos llovió en todas
las fotografías que daban de baja
calidad por la propia lluvia pero era
básicamente
montarse al carro detenerse en una playa
llenar un documento escribir esta playa
para asociar esta playa es para arena
blanca esta playa es para no sé por qué
hay algún espectáculo natural llegan
tortugas llegan ballenas y así fuimos
creando una base de datos sin saber en
ese momento en realidad qué era lo que
queríamos hacer con eso nos nada más
sabíamos que queríamos mapear el país
completo eso era lo que queríamos hacer
y estuvimos un año en accidentado
recuerdo una vez en una carretera
malísimo estado y el cambio se quedó
pegado tuvimos que ver como hacíamos
otra vez en un parque nacional que el
carro no no logramos salir del parque
tuvimos que quedarnos ahí durmiendo
porque no manera de que el guardaparques
nos encontrará no fue fue toda una
aventura de ya en medio de uno de sus
viajes a mí a carlos se nos ocurrió
dijimos si no creemos un buscador de
playas de costa rica y así fue como
nació la inspiración de crear con playa
yo nunca he creído como en las en las
casualidades yo siempre he creído que
todo pasa por alguna razón en la vida
me parece yo no creo que sea una
casualidad que la primera inspiración de
mi vida que fue la posibilidad de estar
en un mundial sirviera para que al mismo
tiempo me haya convertido en periodista
y tampoco creo que esa inspiración de ir
al mundial haya provocado
naciera mi primer emprendimiento todo
fue
desencadenando una serie de factores que
se unieron para que todo pasara para que
pudieras cumplir mi sueño de ir a mi
primer mundial para que pudiera escribir
para que pudiera estar en radio la
conclusión que yo saco de todo esto es
que para cumplir los sueños hay algo que
es esencial y que es inobjetable y es
que la persona que quiera hacerlo
debe encontrar su vocación eso es lo más
importante de todo no tiene que
encontrarla hoy ni mañana no tiene que
encontrarla saliendo del quinto año del
colegio usted puede equivocarse y
tropezar volverá a caer se volverá a
tropezar pero llegará un momento en que
la va a encontrar
y usted tiene que aprender y esta es la
segunda enseñanza de esto al leer
las señales que hay en el camino para
que usted encuentre esa vocación yo no
quise leerlas al principio porque
alguien va a ser tan fiebre de
coleccionar estadísticas porque yo nunca
vi eso porque mi maestra de la escuela
me veía narrando partidos y yo mismo no
me veía así haciendo eso en mi vida
porque
yo sabiendo que mi gran sueño ir en un
mundial y poder estudiar veterinaria yo
mismo tengo claro que no veía las
señales pero el tiempo me enseñó a leer
las señales
cuando usted consiga leer las señales y
cuando después logré encontrar su
vocación que empezar a hacer lo que le
apasiona y que vendrán muchos sueños por
cumplir porque yo no creo que en la vida
hay un único sueño se trata de encontrar
la vocación de hacer lo que le gusta y a
partir de ahí de entrada tendrán
múltiples sueños porque eso se trata de
la vida de estar en constante evolución
somos seres en transformación no se
canse de buscar lo que le gusta no se
canse de buscar su sueño